ici quelques années voire quelques mois
nous serons tous en mesure de produire
notre propre nourriture décentraliser la
production alimentaire chez le
particulier entre utopie et prototypes
où en est-on réellement aujourd'hui
alors pour tout vous dire
cette lubie est devenu très concrètes
pour moi depuis ma participation à poc
21 blocs 21 c'est ce qu'en d'innovation
qui s'est déroulé l'été dernier au
château de millemont dans les yvelines
cent vingt meilleurs ingénieurs
créateurs ont vécu en communauté pendant
près de cinq semaines et ont contribué à
faire émerger 12 solutions aux enjeux
environnementaux actuels
l'idée de ces projets étaient de
décentraliser l'économie pour la rendre
plus résiliente suite à apple 21 tout le
contenu qui a été produit pendant cette
période a été diffusé avec une licence
dites libres ou open source ce qui
signifie simplement que n'importe qui
peut télécharger le contenu technique se
l'approprier le modifier le partager
librement
là on peut se demander pourquoi autant
de personnes ont passé du temps à
s'investir et à contribuer au bien
commun et bien l'idée c'est de fabriquer
de concevoir des solutions innovantes et
surtout une communauté qui va derrière
c'est à dire une communauté qui va
contribuer à faire évoluer à part par
différentes personnes au cours autour du
monde
les solutions de manière très rapide et
je suis là pour en témoigner puisque
c'est typiquement ça qui nous a permis
de passer d'une humble expérimentation
d'arrière cour a aujourd'hui une start
up prometteuses aux ambitions
internationales
rien que ça donc avant d'aller plus loin
je vais revenir un peu sur ces notions
de centralisation décentralisation
qu'est ce qu'on entend par là donc c'est
absolument pas une matrice bien mal
c'est plutôt uniquement un outil on va
dire une grille de lecture qui permet de
classer les institutions les
organisations bien les technologies
donc on pourra dire qu'un système peut
être aussi bien à la fois perçu comme
centralisé ou distribués en fonction de
la composante observez donc je vous
donner deux exemples très simple
d'abord youtube le fameux service de
diffusion de vidéos sur internet qui
pourrait être perçu comme étant
centralisées puisque les infrastructures
qui diffusent des vidéos sont la
priorité de google et en même temps on
pourrait aussi dire que youtube
contribuer à décentraliser la production
d'information puisque n'importe quel
internaute peut diffuser son propre
contenu et dans un tout autre ordre
d'idées la fameuse monnaie
cryptographique le bitcoin pourrait être
perçu comme était en décentralisée par
nature parce qu'elle n'a ni besoin
d'états et encore moins de banques
centrales pour fonctionner et d'un autre
côté on pourrait rétorquer que les
possesseurs de bitcoin et les serveurs
qui la produisent sont tous concentrés
généralement au même endroit on sait pas
chez moi en tout cas rassuré vous donc
maintenant on va voir comment la
décentralisation est en mesure de
répondre aux enjeux majeurs du 21ème
siècle alors ailleurs ces enjeux quels
sont ils
il a tout d'abord l'inépuisable crise
financière qui n'a de cesse de se
prolonger et qui nous laissent
entrapercevoir un monde où le salariat
tel qu'on le connaît et gentiment en
train de disparaître
a priori on ne va pas mourir de faire
tout de suite en europe mais une
question légitime qu'on peut se poser
c'est de savoir comment continuer à se
nourrir sainement avec des revenus
fluctuant variable donc la solution elle
est toute trouvée c'est d'investir une
fois une seule dans un outil de
production et d'en jouir des années et
des années à vous verser les stades
c'est sympa donc ok là la crise
financière donc c'est le premier donc le
réchauffement climatique ensuite alors
le réchauffement climatique qui est dû
aux émissions de gaz à effet de serre
aux transports à la production
centralisée actuelle qui va faire
voyager des salades pendant des
centaines voire des milliers de
kilomètres avant d'arriver à vos
assiettes et donc l'idée c'est
simplement de transformer les terrasses
les balcons les jardins en outil de
production c'est-à-dire approché des
centres de production des centres de
consommation et le troisième enjeu c'est
la perte de confiance des consommateurs
eux mêmes face à d'éventuels
magasin où l'abondance se trouvent
partout des études montrent aujourd'hui
que on efface la plupart du temps à des
aliments qui sont vides alors vide pour
deux raisons la première c'est que les
graines et les semences qui sont
utilisés sont sélectionnés pour des
raisons plus économique que
nutritionnelle et dans un deuxième temps
les seuls pour la plupart sont morts
mais avant ça se voit donc voilà ça se
paye donc comment récupérer cette
confiance à travers la transparence la
transparence sur nature et dont les
graines utilisées mais surtout les
matériaux utilisés et les résultats
obtenus
alors comment la communauté du libre
contribuer à faire émerger des solutions
à ces enjeux là et bien boxer observé
trois moteurs trois moteurs de
l'innovation à premier portait sur les
échanges cet esprit de partage et
d'échangés en retrait dans l'open source
qui à travers les infrastructures de
l'internet à peu près libre est à peu
près accessibles permet de transformer
via des contributions l'information en
connaissance donc c'est les
contributions peuvent apparaître de
partout que ce soit des forums des wikis
des tutoriaux sur youtube et pourquoi
pas des réseaux sociaux
ça sert à ça aussi une fois cette
connaissance disponible et accessible à
tous
un entrepreneur un mec heures un
bricoleur peut se les approprier et
commencer à expérimenter lui-même
quelques quelques trouvailles qui aurait
glané sur internet dans sa cave dans son
jardin et tu commencé pourquoi pas à
documenter ses recherches pour avoir
déjà une première communauté qui n'est
des premières contributions
suite à ça on peut passer à l'étape
supérieure c'est-à-dire passer de
l'artisanat à l'industrialisation donc
c'est le moment d'aller voir des experts
du domaine qui vont un peu discuté de
l'aspect technique et de la profondeur
des marchés des choses vraiment
passionnante et on apparaît on voit
apparaître ainsi voilà de nouveaux
acteurs des acteurs financiers des
acteurs étatiques alors de ses trois
moteurs on voit émerger pas mal de
choses des choses un peu parfois
surprenantes loufoque des générateurs à
plasma grave
voilà c'est un peu surprenant mais
concernant on va dire l'alimentaire ce
qui nous concerne aujourd'hui on a
clairement deux tendances qui
apparaissent d'un côté une tendance très
mental
cartésienne déterministe qui s'appelle
la cacophonie donc ça va beaucoup plaire
aux gadz'arts et de l'autre côté quelque
chose qui est plus dans le passif dans
le nom fer qui s'appelle la permaculture
alors je vais expliquer pour permettre
aux combinés de la permaculture à la
colonie donc je vais expliquer la
permaculture le principe c'est de
recréer la richesse qu'on va retrouver
en forêt c'est à dire quelque chose de
vivant on va dans un premier temps
invité les personnes à recouvrir le sol
lors en forer le sol est toujours
recouvertes
donc on va faire créer un amendement qui
s'appelle du bois raméal fragmenté des
fragments de bois jeunes qui vont garder
le sol toujours plus ou moins humide et
permettre à la vie de se réinstaller
donc les microbes bactéries les
champignons les vers de terre qui vont
vraiment commencer à des compacts et le
sol le rendre dès la plus productifs
ensuite on invite les personnes à aller
un peu plus loin expérimentés qui
s'appelle des buts de permaculture
c'est à dire on va creuser un peu le sol
on va mettre des troncs d'arbres qui
vont récupérer l'eau de pluie et rendre
la butte autonome sur le dessus on va
ajouter un mélange de terre me sableuse
me argileuse est toujours le principal
par la culture numéro un c'est de
toujours tout recouvrir donc rajouter du
bois raméal fragmenté
un autre principe très intéressant là
par la culture c'est l'association de
végétaux donc on va associer des
végétaux qui vont se rendre des petits
services comme par exemple sur le haut
de la butte des tomates qui vont faire
de l'ombre à des salades et on va mettre
quelques plantes aromatiques autour de
la butte pour éloigner certains
nuisibles
la permaculture aussi un des grands
principes c'est d'éviter de retourner le
sol à chaque saison en lutte un peu con
ce réflexe antédiluvien qui consiste à
vouloir un père hâtivement retourner la
terre à chaque saison
mais gardez un écosystème résilient
riche et très productif
ça c'est pour la partie les deux étapes
de permaculture ensuite si on veut
cultiver toute l'année il est
intéressant d'utiliser une serre sous
nos latitudes qui va permettre de
prolonger la sonde maraîchage entre un
mois et demi et deux mois et surtout
proposer une serre connectés alors
pourquoi parce que d'un côté une serre
c'est un outil de production pour soi
mais une serre connectés c'est aussi un
outil citoyen donc on va équiper des
serres de capteurs de température mais
surtout des capteurs de qualité de l'air
extérieur et de radioactivité qui seront
partagés
via des plateformes open source pour
créer un véritable maillage surveillance
citoyens la dernière étape c'est le kop
unis donc j'aurais pu expliquer la coop
aunis et la mise en relation une
symbiose entre des poissons et des
végétaux
donc ce sont des poissons qui vont
produire des déjections dans l'eau
chargée d'ammoniaque qui seront remontés
au niveau de tours de culture vertical
et danser tout en transformant une
transformation chimique entre ammoniac
nitrites et nitrates qui seront
absorbées par les végétaux cette eau il
faut à filtrer retombera directement
dans le bassin avec les poissons on a
réussi ainsi que le faire mais qui va
produire des végétaux en quantité et des
poissons
alors comment ça se présente voici une
configuration avec 24 tours avec deux
bancs de poissons donc la petite pompe
remonte l'eau chargée de nutriments au
sommet de c2c tourner et sur ce type de
configuration avec 24 tours ont produit
plusieurs centaines de kilos de végétaux
par an donc c'est vraiment très
productif c'est jusqu'à huit fois plus
productif que dans le sol le média
utilisé c'est pas de la terre c'est du
pt du plastique alimentaire silicone et
dans lequel les racines peuvent se
déployer sans obstacle et ce qui
favorise aussi phénomène dit de
mycorhizes à sion c'est à dire de
développement bactérien autour de la
racine qui va permettre l'absorption des
minéraux voilà l'instrumentalisation et
nécessaire à ce niveau là donc la
permaculture généralement on va pas
l'approcher par des capteurs par contre
la cua pony on va pas se gêner
on a besoin de surveiller ce qui se
passe autour du péage l'oxygène dissous
du nitrate des nitrites et si on peut
faire ça aujourd'hui et proposer ça aux
particuliers c'est parce que c'est les
technologies open source donc elles sont
accessibles ces capteurs là il ya
quelques années encore il était
complètement inaccessible là on va
pouvoir automatisés
tout ce qui se passe autour de la cua
pony pour le rendre criant marc
accessible aux particuliers
c'est des technologies comme raspberry
fayard dunod des choses comme ça pour
rendre la serre complètement autonome on
a ajouté des panneaux solaires semi
transparent qui laisse passer une
fraction de la lumière et les cellules
photovoltaïques récupère de l'énergie
qui permet d'alimenter ben nasr la pompe
les capteurs et les quelques lumières à
l'intérieur de la serre voilà alors les
solutions existantes finalement quelles
sont les solutions qui ont réussi à
émerger des trois moteurs qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure qui sont donc passés du
stade artisanal au stade industriel
semi-industrielle bien il ya tout
d'abord open-source écologie aux états
unis qui propose un kit de civilisation
clé en main dans quoi ils ont documenté
et tout acquis de civilisation pouvait
faire des maisons des tracteurs et
depuis peu de temps une vision
documenter une serre aqua panic
et ils ont vraiment des résultats assez
impressionnant en termes de génération
de revenus ils ont documenté ça très
très bien ensuite nous avons break tagro
tech qui ôtait états unis nous propose
ces technologies de deux fermes
verticales donc on travaille sur le
volume
ils ont plus comme simon va dire les
fermes urbaines et les pour un tarif
d'entrée qui est pas supérieure à dix
mille euros donc c'est des choses assez
accessible finalement pour démarrer une
activité commerciale et finalement my
food donc une autre s'est reconnecté à
destination des particuliers avec une
approche open source et clé en main donc
on combine un peu ces deux approches
alors pour conclure on peut faire le
parallèle un parallèle assez intéressant
entre le lait repris internet des années
2000 et ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
autour de ces sujets de l'agriculture
urbaine
c'est la même émission c'est la même
énergie finalement qu'on va retrouver à
ce niveau là et pour finir sur une note
un peu plus personnel et une remarque
assez énigmatique
à mon sens l'agriculteur urbain sera
bientôt de nouveaux développeurs php
voilà merci